parce que vous aviez parce que on est
retombé avec l'équipe et ça nous a fait
le week-end quand même on en revient sur
une table accordé beaucoup d'interviews
à l'époque de m6 web et notamment vous
avez accordé une interview à un magazine
qui s'appelle fans de nom c'est très
serré et on a retrouvé alors sans
revenus et les coûts et donc voilà
différentes bulles avec évidemment
différent brest dont la question sur
votre sexy et votre plasma vous disais
que c'était daniela lumbroso donné on
doit aussi regarder les ailes mexique
grave
j'adore sa voix et son physique il ya
aussi moyen que vous me la présentez les
revues de plus théâtral oui bah je dois
bien dire quand même deux trois petites
questions qui méritent qu'on sache qu'on
s'attarde seconde petite copine oui
alors allé au oui oh oui je me lasse
vite faudrait qu'il faut qu'il y ait un
roulement oui j'ai du mal à finir mes
histoires d'amour mais je n'aime pas
parler de ma vie privée je préfère faire
un gage
non j'en ai déjà parlé là enfin voilà il
ya d'autres choses c'est bon
accepterais-tu de poser nue dans un
magazine
bon oui oui bah vous vous seriez vous
appelez même à ce qu'on vous appelle
ah oui d'accord oui mais et puis alors
pour technique de grades de drague faire
marrer les filles parce que femme qui
rit à moitié
[Applaudissements]